BRET.
>> Bret: RICH EDSON AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THANK YOU.
POLITICAL WASHINGTON OBVIOUSLY
BUZZING TONIGHT ABOUT THE
DEPARTURE OF JOHN BOLTON AS THE
PRESIDENT'S NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
JOINING US TONIGHT TO TELL US
WHAT HE KNOWS, SENATE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBER AND
CHAIR OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, LINDSEY GRAHAM OF
SOUTH CAROLINA, THANKS FOR BEING
HERE.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Bret: SEE THIS COMING?
>> A BIT.
A PERSONALITY POLICY DIFFERENCE
THAT LED TO A CHANGE.
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW
JOHN BOLTON SERVE THE COUNTRY
WELL, HE GAVE THE PRESIDENT GOOD
ADVICE, BUT THE ONE THING YOU'VE
GOT TO LEARN BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
AS I'VE COME TO LEARN IS HE'S
UNCONVENTIONAL.
IT'S OKAY I THINK OR TALK WITH
THE TALIBAN EVEN AT CAMP DAVID
IF THERE'S A REASON TO BELIEVE
THEY'RE GOING TO ACCEPT AND
CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR, AND I
THOUGHT WE JUST GOT AHEAD OF THE
CART THERE, BUT JOHN IS GONE AND
THERE ARE A LOT OF THE CHOICES
AND APPRECIATE WHAT JOHN DID FOR
THE COUNTRY.
>> Bret: EVEN A COUPLE DAYS
AHEAD OF 9/11 TO DO THAT AT
CAMP DAVID?
>> YEAH.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THE TIMING, BUT
THE MAIN THING IS -- I TOLD THE
PRESIDENT YOUR RIGHT TO WANT TO
REDUCE OUR COMMITMENT.
YOUR RIGHT TO WANT TO LOWER OUR
COSTS.
18 YEARS LATER, WHAT HAVE WE
FOUND?
AL QAEDA IS STILL THERE, ISIS IS
THERE.
BUT THE AFGHAN ARMY IS 270,000.
18 YEARS AGO THEY DIDN'T HAVE AN
ARMY.
6 MILLION WOMEN IN SCHOOL, A LOT
OF POSITIVE THINGS.
THERE'S A LOT OF BAD THINGS AND
WE CAN'T DO IN AFGHANISTAN WHAT
WE DID IN IRAQ, IGNORE SOUND
MILITARY ADVICE AND PULL THE
PLUG ON THE PLACE, BUT HAVING
SAID THAT, I'D LIKE TO END THE
WAR.
THE ONLY WAY YOU EVER END THE
WAR IS TO GET THE TWO SIDES
TALKING SO IT'S OKAY TO TALK
WITH THE TALIBAN.
IT WOULD BE OKAY TO COME TO
CAMP DAVID BUT WHAT I THOUGHT
WAS A MISTAKE IS -- WELL, THE
BIG MISTAKE IF THE TALIBAN
REALLY SCREWED UP WHEN IT CAME
TO TRUMP.
IF THIS AN INSULT OF THE
PRESIDENT TO KILL THAT SOLDIER
WHILE HE'S TRYING TO END THE
WAR.
I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO REGRET
THIS.
I THINK THE TALIBAN ARE REALLY
GOING TO REGRET WHAT THEY DID.
>> Bret: WHAT YOU SAY TWO
ALLIES WILL LOOK AT THE TURMOIL
INSIDE THE ADMINISTRATION?
THERE HAVE BEEN 60 INDIVIDUALS
IN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION,
EITHER RESIGNED OR BEEN FIRED,
SOME OF THEM ON THE PAGE HERE.
WHAT YOU SAY TO THOSE ALLIES --
IT'S VOLATILE, UNCERTAIN.
LOOKING NOW AT THE FORCE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR IN
THREE YEARS PLUS?
>> HERE'S WHAT I WOULD SAY TO
ALLIES, JUDGE US BY WHAT WE DO.
WE REDUCED OUR PRESENCE IN SYRIA
BUT WE STILL HAVE A COMMITMENT
TO NORTHEASTERN SYRIA TO PROTECT
THE KURDS AND MAKE SURE IRAN
DOESN'T TAKE OVER.
WE GOT OFF IN IRAN DEAL THAT I
THOUGHT WAS A BAD DEAL AND THE
PRESIDENT KEPT HIS WORD.
HE'S TRYING TO REDUCE OUR
COMMITMENT IN AFGHANISTAN THAT
MAKES SENSE TO ME, WE ARE PAYING
WAY TOO MUCH MONEY 18 YEARS
LATER AND WE CAN REDUCE OUR
FORCES AND BE SAFE HERE, BUT WE
JUST CAN'T PULL OUT OF THE
PLACE.
I WOULD SAY TO OUR ALLIES, WHY
DON'T YOU HELP HIM MORE?
>> Bret: IT WAS IRAN A POLICY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT
OF JOHN BOLTON?
MAYBE THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO
MEET WITH THEIR PRESIDENT, MAYBE
EVEN AT THE U.N.
GENERAL ASSEMBLY?
>> I THINK BOLTON LOOKED AT
TRUMP THROUGH THE TRADITIONAL
FOREIGN POLICY LENS.
THE CONDITION WAS HIM, YOU DON'T
TALK TO GUYS COMING TO ELEVATE
KIM JONG UN.
I DON'T CARE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
KIM JONG UN GO ON VACATION.
IF THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES TO GIVE
HIM UP -- GIVE UP HIS NUCLEAR
WEAPONS, I'M OKAY WITH PERSONAL
DIPLOMACY THAT'S UNCONDITIONAL.
I'M OKAY WITH TALKING TO THE
IRANIANS AS LONG AS WE GET A
BETTER DEAL.
WHAT WOULD A BETTER DEAL BE?
THEY CAN HAVE NUCLEAR POWER BUT
THEY CAN'T ENRICH A PROCESS OF
URANIUM, THAT WOULD BE A BETTER
DEAL SO I'M NOT HERE TO MUCH OF
THE PRESENT.
YOU BEAT ME, 16 OF THE
REPUBLICANS COMING TO BEAT
HILLARY CLINTON.
LET'S GIVE YOUR WAY TO TRY AND
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT A MOLOKAN.
>> Bret: LOOKING AT
NORTH KOREA AS A BLUEPRINT, WHAT
DO YOU SEE OUT OF THOSE
NEGOTIATIONS AND THOSE TWO
SUMMITS?
>> I SEE BETTER.
NO NEED FOR MUSCLE TESTING, NO
BOMBS BEING EXPLODED.
A PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP -- HOW
WILL THAT WORK OUT?
THOSE WHO CRITICIZE THE PRESENT,
HOW WELL DID YOU DO ANY WRONG?
HOW WELL DID YOU DO IN
NORTH KOREA?
I'M A PRETTY HAWKISH GUY BUT
AFTER 18 YEARS, IT'S OKAY TO
REEVALUATE OUR COMMITMENT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE TO ME,
BUT I'M JUST URGING THE
PRESIDENT DON'T IGNORE SOUND
MILITARY ADVICE.
YOU CAN REDUCE OUR PRESENCE IN
AFGHANISTAN BUT IF YOU LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN, AL QAEDA AND ISIS
ARE COMING AFTER US.
>> Bret: SO DID HE FIRE HIM OR
DID BOLTON RESIGN?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT I DON'T
THINK IT REALLY MATTERS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY I LIKED
JOHN BOLTON.
HE SERVED HONORABLY AND AS
PRESIDENT LOST TRUST AND FAITH
IN JOHN BOLTON AND I THINK HE'S
GOT SOME GOOD CHOICES.
>> Bret: LET'S TALK ABOUT
THAT.
IF YOU TALKED ABOUT THAT TODAY.
WHO'S ON THE PLATE?
>> GENERAL KELLOGG IS THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR TO
MIKE PENCE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT, HE WORKED
FOR GENERAL McMASTER.
>> Bret: KEITH KELLOGG.
>> KEEP KELLOGG.
CONFIDENT, CAPABLE, CONFIDENT,
HAS THE PRESIDENT'S TRUST.
A DYNAMIC YOUNG MAN WORKING IN
THE STATE DEPARTMENT, PART OF
THE IRAN TEAM AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT CLOSE TO
POMPEO.
YOU'VE GOT REQUIRE DELL, WHO
WORKED FOR McMASTER WHO KNOWS
THE INS AND OUTS OF THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL AND THE WAY IT
MEETS.
THE ONE THING I THINK WAS A
KNOCK ON JOHN BOLTON IS THE
PROCESS KIND OF DIED ON HIS
WATCH.
>> Bret: THESE ARE THE THREE
GUYS.
KEEP KELLOGG, BRIAN, RECORD OUT.
>> THOSE ARE THREE NAMES THE
PRESIDENT MENTIONED TO ME.
THERE ARE OTHERS ON THE LIST,
BUT WHAT ARE WE LOOKING FOR?
SOMEBODY THAT CAN WORK WITH
POMPEO, WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE TO GET THE INNER
AGENCY BACK -- STOOD BACK UP.
>> Bret: 'S DOESN'T REQUIRE
SENATE CONFIRMATION VOTE.
THIS IS JUST ABOUT TRUST WITH
THE PRESIDENT, RIGHT?
>> IT'S ABOUT UNDERSTANDING THE
PRESIDENT TRYING TO ENACT HIS
WILL BUT TELLING THE TRUTH.
HERE'S THE TRUTH AND HERE IS HOW
I GET ALONG WITH HIM.
THIS PRESIDENT, YOU'RE RIGHT TO
WANT TO REDUCE OUR COMMITMENT
AFGHANISTAN, REDUCE THE COST AND
MAYBE REDUCE THE TROOP LEVELS.
BUT IT WOULD BE A BIG MISTAKE TO
DO IN AFGHANISTAN WHAT OBAMA DID
IN IRAQ.
I'M LOOKING FOR A NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR WHO UNDERSTANDS
THE PRESIDENT, CAN WORK WITH
OTHERS, GIVE THE PRESIDENT GOOD
ADVICE AND BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
PUSH BACK WHEN HE NEEDS TO.
>> Bret: I WANT TO ASK YOU TWO
MORE QUESTIONS.
ONE, THERE'S AN INVESTIGATION
OUT OF COMMERCE SECRETARY
WILBUR ROSS, IF HE PUT HIS
FINGER ON THE SCALE AND NOAA
SCIENTISTS IN THE FALL OF THE
ALABAMA ORDEAL WE DEALT WITH
LAST WEEK.
WHAT'S YOUR THOUGHTS IN MY?
>> NOT GOING TO GIVE A --
>> Bret: THAT'S FOR THE
RECORD?
>> YEAH, THANK YOU.
NEXT QUESTION.
I COULD CARELESS, THIS WHOLE
THING IS A BUNCH OF GARBAGE.
IF THE PRESIDENT DID HAVE A
MODEL WHERE IT COULD HAVE
ALABAMA IF IT WENT THROUGH
FLORIDA.
THIS IS THE TRUMP WORLD.
THE GUY CAN'T DO ANYTHING, THE
GUY GETTING CRITICIZED BY A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO JUST HATE
HIS GUTS AND I'M NOT PLAYING
THAT GAME.
>> Bret: THE STORY ABOUT THE
RUSSIAN ASSET THAT WAS
EXTRACTED.
>> ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF WHAT I
THINK IS COMPLETE B.S., TRYING
TO BLAME THE PRESIDENT FOR
SOMETHING THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
NETWORKS OUT THERE SAYING THE
PRESIDENT GOT A LOAN COSIGNED BY
OLIGARCHS.
WHEN IT COMES TO TRUMP, I'M VERY
SUSPICIOUS -- YOU SAY IT AND
THEN YOU TRY TO VERIFY IT LATER.
THE PRESIDENT IS A HANDFUL.
HE MAKES HIS FAIR SHARE OF
MISTAKES, BUT THE STORY ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT DAMAGING OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY I THINK IS
UNVERIFIED AND UNTRUE.
>> Bret: ARE YOU CONFIDENT
THAT THE FUNDING OF THE
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO GO
WITHOUT A BUMP?
>> IT MAY BE A BUMP, BUT IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE FAILURE
IS NOT AN OPTION.
BOTH PARTIES NEED TO CONVINCE
THE PUBLIC WE ARE NOT COMPLETELY
CRAZY.
AND WE CAN DO OUR JOB.
>> Bret: LAST THING, ANYTHING
GET DONE BEFORE 2020 IN EARNEST?
>> I THINK WE MAY HAVE SOME
BREAKTHROUGHS ON SOLVING THE
PLASTIC IN THE OCEANS PROBLEM.
WE MAY HAVE SOME BREAKTHROUGHS
ON INFRASTRUCTURE, A SMALLER
BILL, FUNDING THE GOVERNMENT
WOULD BE A GREAT STEP FORWARD,
GIVING THE MILITARY WHAT THEY
NEED.
ON IMMIGRATION, YOU MIGHT HAVE A
DEAL WITH THE DACA POPULATION IF
THE COURT RULES THAT OBAMA'S